je suis en arrière il y a un frère ça
venait comme on veut
oui il faut qu'il soit comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça
de Rabbi a inventée par Gérard Oury sera
l'une des productions françaises les
plus importantes de l'année pour les
besoins du film il a d'abord fallu
transformer tout un quartier de
Saint-Denis et laisser la place aux
décorateurs qui sont les premiers
fabricants d'illusion
pour imiter la pierre maintenant c'est
n'importe quel matériau et ensuite c'est
le talent des camarades ici présents
qu'on appelle peintre décorateur qui est
portant de n'importe quel matériau
sont les imitations les plus
invraisemblables pour ce film dont le
budget dépasse le milliard Gérard Oury a
pu réunir deux équipes un directeur de
la photographie et un ingénieur du son
parmi les plus réputés de nombreux
techniciens que le cinéma français
n'emploie pas d'habitude comme cette
personne chargée du choix des acteurs de
ce qu'on appelle en Amérique le casting
c'est un métier qui n'existe
pratiquement pas en France pour moi pour
moi personnellement je crois que c'est
présenté au metteur en scène des
comédiens qui ne prend jamais ou en tout
cas rarement vous en avez présenté
beaucoup pour ce film je
crois que j'ai fait tout parler et même
les tranchées
mais vous ne le cachez
des personnages même des groupes par
exemple dans ce film il y a un groupe
d'Arabes de
[Musique]
on choisit une couleur j'ai choisi une
couleur une gamme de coloris en restant
des camaïeu de beige et de brun pour
qu'on trouve toujours les mêmes
personnages on les retrouve grâce à la
couleur et chapeau
normalement ils se mettent droit mais
vous pouvez le mettre en arrière si vous
voulez
je travaille comme vous pouvez le voir
en ce moment c'est à dire que nous avons
cette caméra
anal vision qui est là et qui est sur sa
grue je vais faire maintenant un plan
qui est défini que j'ai défini ce matin
en arrivant sur le tournage et puis
alors en même temps j'ai deux autres
appareils qui virevoltent autour de
Messein et qui font si vous voulez un
certain nombre de plans tout à fait
improvisé et au montage on mélange
ces différents plans avec des
conceptions différentes et ça donne de
très bons résultats j'avais déjà fait
pour la folie des grandeurs et j'ai
perfectionné un peu le système pour ce
film là donnez-moi des oranges
alors attention s'il vous plaît alors là
dès que tu as dès que tu as donné cette
corbeille donne la corbeille à
l'intérieur prends la clôture
merci merci
passe de l'Intérieur
en scène bien entendu qu'il reste le
maître d'oeuvre qui reste le patron de
son film mais avec lui on s'entend
pour savoir quelle est la nature de la
photographie qu'on va donner l'art du
chemin opérateur d'une part c'est de
faire une continuité dans une séquence
pour les atmosphères et d'autre part
d'éclairer les vedettes toujours sous un
jour favorable
à combien tu es à la fin
des choses en vieillissant on se
découvre des choses
on dirait
bien sûr c'est le metteur en scène qui
commande mais l'impératif économique
emporte certaines décisions
depuis quelques années beaucoup de
choses parce que dès qu'il y a le moins
de rose dès qu'il y a le moindre en lui
on vous dit on va doubler et c'est
vraiment désagréable ça sert à rien de
on prend tout tes précautions moments de
tourner vous voyez bon vous dit bah je
sais on fait du son témoin c'est nos
amis italiens qui ont
instauré ce système du doublage quelle
est l'avantage
aucun mais est-ce qu'il n'y a pas des
qualités de son qu'on ne peut obtenir
qu'en studio et qui sont peut-être
meilleurs que des sons directs je le
crois pas du tout pas du tout vous qui
êtes déjà actualistes vous devriez pas
dire ça vous devriez penser qu'il y a
une vérité une et puis il arrive il y a
un état de grâce qui existe dans
l'extérieur bon on va envoyer on va
tourner voilà on va s'y mettre voilà on
y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]